okay let's talk about Fox News's Laura
Ingraham you might recall that Fox News
host Laura Ingraham took what sort of
seemed like an abrupt vacation after
about a dozen of her advertisers stopped
buying ads on her show as a result of
her comments about david hog david hog
is a student from the parkland Florida
high school that suffered a mass
shooting a few weeks ago and david hog
himself after laura ingraham did this
called for a boycott of her show an
advertiser boycott of her show on
twitter and on a dozen or more a really
dozens of companies that were
advertising on her program and before
her abrupt vacation about a dozen of
those companies had already bailed and
then she very very quickly announced
that she was taking a week off for
Easter it's possible that that week off
was pre-planned and it just wasn't
mentioned it might not have been the
timing of it was pretty weird but she
did return right that was part of the
question because when Bill O'Reilly
ultimately lost his program on Fox News
he took a very sudden week or two off
was it a week or two I don't remember
and very quickly thereafter the show
went away but Laura Ingraham did come
back but not too good news and in fact
the number of advertisers dropping her
show increased from 12 to 20 by the time
she was back for her first post Easter
break show on Monday and that's at least
20 advertisers that have dropped her
show that we know about and the latest
one here is Allstate Insurance the
difference seems to be that Allstate is
kind of being more subtle so there are
companies that when they decided to drop
advertising with Laura Ingraham they
tweeted about it they put out a press
release about it they made it known that
they were pulling ads and if media
reached out to them to say are you
pulling ads they would say yes Allstate
is taking a bit of a different approach
they've not been answering questions
they were asked to confirm that they
pulled ads and they said we've taken
note of your concerns which isn't an
at all to the question of are you still
answering advertising on the program
they were asked are more ads scheduled
to run on laura ingraham show and
allstate said we cannot answer that
question so they might be taking the
more subtle approach which is they're
dropping the ads but they're not making
noise about it Ace Hardware took that
approach men's clothing store Joseph a
bank said listen we were never actually
buying on laura ingraham show we were
buying generally on Fox News but Joseph
a bank ads have sort of mysteriously or
not so mysteriously disappeared from
laura ingraham show as well and I'm kind
of mixed about this the the subtle
strategy the subtle strategy of pulling
the ads because on the one hand I like
the idea of just pulling the ads quietly
not making a big hubbub for publicity
and just saying we're just not going to
fund the program anymore but it can also
be sort of a calculated thing right
because you might say well pull the ads
the people that are paying close
attention to who's advertising will
notice it and they'll reward you they'll
be happy right the people who are on the
sort of the side of David hog but by
subtly pulling the ads without making an
actual announcement about it maybe the
people that would boycott you for
pulling the ads won't notice because
you're not drawing attention to it in
any case the pulling of the ads is a
good thing and there there's still
people saying these are limits on free
speech this is a form of censorship it's
just such a bogus perspective and a
misunderstanding of what censorship and
free speech really are I was actually
talking yesterday about this with stamp
seat or host of the majority report it's
good not to fund propaganda it's good
not to fund people who criticize
students at high schools that suffered
mass shootings right it is objectively
good and people will say to me but David
you could be hurt by that same sword
that's a double edged sword if I support
the boycotts by advertisers of other
programs to the point that those
programs could go out of business I also
could be the tar
of the same type of advertiser boycott
listen if I say something that is so
upsetting to people and so disturbing
and so horrible that my audience
activates or people not in my audience
and go to advertisers and say look at
what David said pull your money if I'm
saying despicable things then the case
can be made that I deserve to be
boycotted and that my speech has
consequences and my speech having
consequences is not the same as some
kind of blanket censorship or
restriction on free speech and people
will remind me of YouTube's ad pocalypse
that was not a targeted boycott of me
for the things I said it was horrible
and I am completely against what
happened and everybody knows the extent
to which it hurt the program during 2017
but that was something that happened to
cross news and politics it happened to
conservatives and liberals and it was
about advertisers becoming sort of
skittish about having their ads appear
on edgy content or controversial content
that is completely different than me
saying something and then that speech
having consequences and advertisers are
free to make the choice about where to
support me whether to support me or not
we have a good relationship with the
advertisers that we have and who would
it who would I be to say you can't
decide on the basis of my content
whether or not to keep advertising so
good luck convincing it to the fans of
Laura Ingraham this has nothing to do
with censorship this has nothing to do
with free speech this has to do with
companies with a profit motive making
decisions using whatever barometer they
have whatever rubric they have to decide
where do we advertise and where don't we
advertise and I'm glad that 20 or more
advertisers are saying we're not going
to advertise with Laura Ingraham anymore
give us a like on Facebook facebook.com
slash David Pakman show we will take a
quick break and be back with more after
this